friedensaktivisten vermuten dort die
und jetzt das heute journal mit gundula
an der kampfzone und man rechnet damit
und haben geweint und sie unsere auch
operation bigbank von
bringt die menschen raus aus der ost
letzten noch in deutschland
russische armee an dieser stelle einfach
stationierten atomwaffen zentrale
dass die kampfzone auch diesen ort
ukraine
eine freiwillige wollen sie auch hat
1947 gedacht bei dem großen knall
druck machen will auf die ukraine man
eine lange fahrt morgen wollen sie in
gause und bettina schausten
russischen angriffen viele tote gibt
jetzt angerufen und gesagt komm her
erreichen wird
forderung aller ostermärsche ein
holzes oft hierher aus der zusammenbruch
530 kilometer geht es richtung ost
abend an diesem ostermontag die
hat mit diesen angriffen den ganzen land
viele zivile opfer davon kein wort so
detonierten 6700 tonnen munition
polen seien
waffenstillstand in der ukraine und das
noch einmal gezeigt so was man fähig ist
ukraine auch eine kurze panne hält sie
feiertage haben die innenpolitische
war hier vor der zentralen erstaufnahme
wie in mario pohl
fast fünf millionen menschen haben die
ende des russischen angriffskrieges
alle ehemaligen nazi anlagen auf der
und es wurden ja auch in lemberg
debatte über waffenlieferungen an die
nicht auf zwölf stunden später erreichen
auf den straßen leichen die häuser in
in hamburg zurzeit ist es dort ruhig
ukraine inzwischen verlassen mehr als
eisenbahnlinien bombardiert die sind
insel wurden zerstört die bis dahin
ukraine gedämpft zu ende ist sie nicht
schutzsuchende aus der ukraine kommen
die hälfte davon sind nach polen
silos super es muss jetzt schnell gehen
gesundheitsminister lauterbach hat mit
schutt und asche gebombt noch immer
größte sprengung weltweit veränderte die
geflogen um sich in sicherheit zu
nötig für waffen aus dem westen zu
weniger an die freiwilligen helfer wie
seiner warnung vor einer möglichen so
die rufe aus der ukraine an die
hilfsgüter auslagen jederzeit könnte es
warten die menschen darauf aus der stadt
bringen auch um nicht allzu weit weg zu
transportieren lemberg im westen ist ja
genannten killer variante des corona
claudia kraemer sind trotzdem geblieben
zu kommen bislang ohne erfolg auch heute
oberfläche der felseninsel nachhaltig
westlichen partner schnell mit schweren
beschuss geben die russischen truppen
die stadt wo auch die ganzen waffen noch
sein von der heimat der polnische
die stadt beschränkt sich derzeit auf
virus kritik ausgelöst der virologe
sind nicht weit
wieder
waffen zu helfen sind laut und dringlich
durch durch müssen und deswegen ist es
grenzschutz berichtet heute dass
ähnliche bilder auch aus kharkiv hier
fehle noch die wetteraussichten die
das nötigste man macht sich nicht
schmidt-chanasit sagte der bild zeitung
wir gehen ja verlässt nur schweren
inzwischen und tag mehr flüchtlinge in
verständlich dass die russische armee an
inzwischen sieht kiew anzeichen dafür
überwiegend frühlingshaft bleiben nur im
abhängig von irgendwelchen behörden und
die sei unwissenschaftlich und
wurden nach ukrainischen angaben in den
herzens ihren heimatort ihre eltern
die ukraine zurück kehren als nach polen
auflagen man macht es so wie man es
dass die erwartete offensive im osten
südosten überwiegen die wolken in der
letzten tagen mindestens 18 menschen
verunsichere laut whu sei eine killer
dieser stelle auch zuge dieser offensive
wollen bleiben
einreisen ein gewaltiges risiko auch
möchte dem herzen entsprechend also ich
getötet und über 100 verletzt
des landes beginnen
hier diese diese wichtige infrastruktur
lausitz in nieder und oberbayern kann es
variante ein unwahrscheinliches szenario
wir gehen weil die kinder leiden und
gleichzeitig verstärkt russland seine
wenn gebiete als zurückerobert gelten
möchte einfach was machen ich kann nicht
bombardiert
schauer geben sonst bleibt es trocken
auch der virologe streik erklärte man
nichts tun helfer und dolmetscher sind
bei viel sonne in der osthälfte 7 bis 14
evakuiert wohin sie greifen mittlerweile
dankeschön für heute abend dominik
luftangriffe auch wieder auf ziele im
weinen kampfflugzeuge fliegen es gibt
das
könne die entwicklung von varianten
bundesinnenministerium gab die zahl der
rar mischa ist elf seine eltern sind vor
löschmeister und wir bleiben bei dominik
die ganze ukraine an sie haben heute
westen heute morgen traf ist lemberg
explosionen es ist einfach hoffnungslos
in der westhälfte 14 bis 20 grad ab
nicht vorhersagen
nach deutschland geflüchteten heute mit
langer zeit aus russland gekommen und
lemberg angegriffen und mehr pro überall
ich mache mir sorgen um meine eltern es
im zuge des corona ausbruchs in shanghai
sein bericht zeigt uns jetzt einen
ulrike rödl beginnt damit ihren bericht
verabscheuen putins krieg so oft er kann
gut
mittwoch mehr wolken im norden und osten
schlagen sie zu
freiwilligen helfer aus deutschland der
357.000 an um sie kümmern sich überall
haben die behörden der chinesischen
ist micha da um zu helfen und um zu
menschen aus dem osten der ukraine
jetzt offenbar auch vermehrt im osten
am freitag kann es am alpenrand regnen
die raketenangriffe kamen am morgen fünf
millionenmetropole die ersten todesfälle
heißt abschied nehmen von den männern
im land ehrenamtliche nachbarschaft
herausholt das ist eine gefährliche
übersetzen
etwa 50 kilometer von grammatik entfernt
die noch im ort sind viele frauen sind
gemeldet es soll sich um drei ältere vor
10 bis 21 grad
netzwerke freundeskreise solidarität ins
seien es insgesamt gewesen sein eine
aufgabe nicht selten sind autos busse
micha überbringt die gute nachricht eine
aber mit ihren kindern bereits alleine
hier sollen russische truppen ihre
soweit unser blick auf den ostermontag
erkrankte handeln die nicht geimpft
druckwelle zerstört die fensterscheiben
da und ohne sie ginge es gar nicht aber
unsere partner bei der ukrainischen
flüchtende in den letzten wochen gezielt
der helferinnen bringt die ukrainische
offensive begonnen haben der krieg in
gewesen sein täglich gibt es derzeit in
einer unterkunft hier hatten menschen
armee
um 23 50 gibt es hier die schnelle
viele helferinnen und helfer kommen nach
familie zum hauptbahnhof
beschossen worden für die menschen die
schutz gesucht die aus anderen regionen
der ukraine er dauert nun schon 54 tage
wochen der unterstützung inzwischen an
china mehr als 20.000 neuinfektionen
gehen und damit lange gewartet haben ist
ich hatte meine zweifel weil ich meinen
nachrichtenüberblick in einer heute
der ukraine geflohen waren auch eine
ihre grenzen wenn regen berichtet aus
mischa der harry potter aus
express so ist es und bis morgen
fast alle in shanghai die hafenstadt ist
es die vielleicht letzte chance ein
mann der in der territorialverteidigung
ja dominique weltmeister ist für uns in
autowerkstatt wurde zerstört und teile
hamburg-rahlstedt zaubert mit wörtern
hamburg helena und jens volk sind am
ist nicht zurücklassen wollte ich mache
seit ende märz weitgehend im lockdown
alter linienbus als lebensretter in kiel
die stadt entzaubert mit solchen
kiew dominik es gibt eben heute abend
der bahnstrecke
limit seit die ersten schutz suchen denn
mir natürlich sorgen um ihr
flugblättern auf deutsch
millionen menschen dürfen ihre wohnungen
diese meldungen dass die offensive der
verlagen sie hilfsgüter kochen essen für
etwas traf das nachbarhaus dann
aus der ukraine in hamburg ankamen
russischen armee begonnen habe oder
nicht verlassen
einen kurzen magischen moment hat auch
mitnehmen können sie nur einen kleinen
zerbrachen die scheiben wir hatten angst
organisieren die beiden was staatliche
die menschen die sie raus bringen wollen
in schweden ist es in mehreren städten
haben könnte was können sie uns dazu
und wussten nicht was wir tun sollten
stellen wie hier in hamburg bis heute
helen nachfolgt der ausflug an die
aus der umkämpften ost ukraine ralf
koffer ein paar persönliche dinge die
also haben wir angefangen zu bieten
sagen
nicht schaffen sie verteilen flüchtlinge
ostsee ist für sie eine reise in die
bei protesten gegen kundgebungen einer
kubon kommt aus deutschland er ist einer
menschen hier haben eine traumatische
vergangenheit ihre familie kam über das
direkt auf gastfamilien und sie bleiben
ja zumindest mal verdichten sich die
rechtsextremen partei zu schweren
zeit hinter sich
der gründer der hilfsorganisation eines
der bürgermeister von lemberg spricht
spätaussiedler abkommen nach deutschland
in kontakt denn immer häufiger passt es
hinweise dass diese offensive in der ost
ausschreitungen gekommen auslöser waren
meine kinder und enkelkinder sind
ihr ziel menschen den krisengebieten in
von mindestens sechs toten darunter auch
ukraine begonnen hat der ukrainische
nicht es gibt natürlich auch dass
bereits geflohen sie sind jetzt den
sicherheit bringen geplant ist die
koranverbrennungen eines rechtsextremen
ein kind
generalstab otto abend zitat anzeichen
familien die einfach nicht
pulheim bei köln ich war allein hier ich
evakuierung eines dorfs wir haben
als jetzt und anderen gedanken auch ein
zusammenpassen und
politikers wie hier in northampton
wir wenden uns an die ganze welt damit
bin schon lehrerin hier kann ich keine
konfrontiert man natürlich also und da
der des beginns der offensive quasi
kontakt man da vor ort dass es sehr nah
zündeten randalierer fahrzeuge an und
gewinn so ein bisschen in mich hinein
kinder mehr unterrichten
jeder es versteht wenn wir den feind
versuchen wir auch die beiden fällen
ich habe mich entschieden zu gehen die
meister und
beschädigten gebäude 15
genannt das ist sozusagen für uns dass
klarzumachen entfernt da macht er das
nicht stoppen und aus unserem land
wie nötig diese pausen für die
vertreiben dann wird er immer
gegendemonstranten und 26 polizisten
hälfte ist geschafft für ralf über den
oder erträgt diese reibereien und die
das das hätte ihn heta hinweis darauf
weitermachen
freiwilligen helfer sind haben sie schon
wurden verletzt
deutschen helfer gleich geht es los dass
dazu passt dass das russische
dass ist in dieser nacht los geht es
gemerkt eine mitorganisatorin musste ins
dauerhafte doppelbelastung mit beruf und
heute vor 75 jahren sprengte die
verteidigungsministerium heute diese
er aus dem alter kommt die flut
gibt auch meldungen aus hacke von donuts
privater hilfe
krankenhaus die emotionale belastung war
katastrophe erlebte einer seiner
bilder präsentiert raketenangriffe auf
von vorstößen der russischen truppen und
britische airforce alle militäranlagen
zehrt an nerven und kostet kraft der
beweggründe hier zu helfen wenn man das
einfach zu groß
mehrere städte man sei so ein sprecher
das pasta mit zusammen dass auch der
der wehrmacht auf helgoland mit einem
gemeinsame urlaubstag an der ostsee ist
gefühl kennen da von der einen auf die
ja und lässt sich nicht einfach
erfolgreich gewesen ziel waren die
ukrainische generalstab gesagt hat dass
eine persönliche ruheoase ein kurzer
andere nacht alles zu verlieren dann
gottesdienst wurde auf helgoland der
abstellen wir machen hier nun weiter mit
regionen noch faxe briefe und j
glaube ich bekomme man einen ganz guten
die vorbereitung der russischen truppen
moment in dem die bilder aus lenas
nachrichten und gundula gause
beendet sein
heimat aber trotzdem präsent sind zwei
impuls dazu anderen menschen helfen er
der ukraine krieg war das beherrschende
dass also die situation im osten der
die russischen luftabwehrsysteme haben
meiner begriff zusammengebrochen straße
thema der ostermärsche an denen sich
westen der ukraine schien bisher
heute insgesamt sechs ukrainische
vergleichsweise sicher was bedeuten die
bundesweit tausende beteiligt haben auch
kampfflugzeuge abgeschossen außerdem elf
heute gab es in rund 30 städten
luftangriffe auf lemberg die wir gerade
ukrainische drohnen dass es bei den
gesehen haben auf lemberg zum jetzigen
friedensdemonstrationen darunter am
luftwaffenstützpunkt büchel in der eifel
zeitpunkt ja ich glaube dass die
[Musik]